[Applaus]
corona nachgehakt
rückte frieden also der alltag vor der
korona pandemie näher wie weit sind wir
auf dem weg von der pandemie in die ndm
nach den aktuellen informationen aber
eine höher als zunächst berechnet die
impfquote scheint eine neue cola welle
im winter unwahrscheinlich oder ich
spreche mit dem virologen hendrik strikt
den ist herzlich begrüße
hattrick werden wir es schaffen diese
neue welle im winter zu verhindern
dadurch dass doch mehr geimpft sind als
wir gedacht haben also erstmal sind das
ja gute nachrichten dass mehr menschen
geimpft sind als man angenommen hat ja
in den letzten
monaten auch schon immer mal die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung darauf
hingewiesen aber wir wissen oder ein
problem was wir ja sehen dabei ist dass
wir gar nicht genau wissen wie viele
menschen geimpft sind also das ist bei
eine repräsentative umfrage bei der vom
robert koch institut die 1000 menschen
befragt hat und da kam sogar eine
einfache impfquote von 87 prozent heraus
und man hat das dann verglichen mit dem
ausgegebenen impfdosen und hat es dann
runtergerechnet auf einfache impfung auf
84 prozent aber ich glaube das problem
was wir hier bei sehen wieder mal ist
dass das robert-koch-institut gar nicht
genau weiß wie viele geimpft sind und
was sich ja ein bisschen durch zieht
durch die pandemie dass ihr da so ein
bisschen eine daten wüste haben und zu
schlecht eigentlich bescheid wissen wie
die pandemie in deutschland aussieht
aber ist das nicht auch ein problem weil
wir das immer aufgrund der zahlen dann
der politik sozusagen präsentieren als
virologe als epidemiologe nun machen wir
das weil wir haben hier die zahlen und
du musst jetzt darüber entscheiden was
es für einschränkungen gibt ja ich sehe
das schon als kritisch ein und viele
statistiker haben na ja immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen gerd antes daniel
harke haben immer wieder gesagt wir
müssen besser die daten in deutschland
erfassen england macht das zum beispiel
in der weise dass sie repräsentative
stichproben zieht und immer im panel
sich quasi anschaut wie viele menschen
eigentlich infiziert oder nicht aber im
moment wissen wir ja zum beispiel gar
nicht wie häufig im durchbrüche in
deutschland stattfinden da geimpft fast
nie getestet werden bleibt das impfen im
augenblick die zentrale lösung für das
problem corona weil wir haben ja jetzt
auch immer mal wieder zwischendurch
meldungen es gibt medikamente
entwicklungen vielleicht wäre das ja
auch angelogen also die impfung ist
wirklich ein zentraler bestandteil und
wir haben ja auch noch eine ganze anzahl
an genesenen die wir gar nicht in diese
schutz quote eigentlich mit rein rechnen
und die man ja auch über antikörper test
gut bestimmen könnte und wissen würde ob
diese menschen schon auch geschützt sind
ich glaube wir rechnen da ein bisschen
pessimistisch gelegen wahrscheinlich in
unser schutz quote an die 90 prozent
wenn wir die den genesenen status
richtig bestimmen würden und auch
genießen und mit einbeziehen würden bei
der medikamentenentwicklung ist es immer
schwierig in der entwicklung das
vorherzusagen aber
nokia wir was das neue medikament von
merck ist also msd hat sehr gute daten
vorgelegt was uns vielleicht
zusätzlichen im herbst und winter helfen
kann ist ein solches medikament dann
eine bessere lösung als die impfungen
die impfung das schöne an der impfung
ist da wird das eigene immunsystem
trainiert und da werden ja nur
bestandteile vom virus gezeigt und das
immunsystem macht es selber und kämpft
kann selber das virus gut bekämpfen
dieses medikament monika wir ist zeigt
vor allem eine wirkung wenn man es sehr
früh ein nimmt also um 50 prozent
reduktionen der krankenhausaufenthalte
und auch todesfälle hat man gesehen wenn
man das sehr früh eingenommen hat und
man kann sich das so an dem setting
vorstellen dass es wenn es zum beispiel
im altenheim ausbruch gegeben hat das
dann vorsorglich die anderen bewohner
ein medikament als quasi eine post
exposition prophylaxe wie wir das nennen
oder projekts positions- prophylaxe und
sich dadurch eine krankheit oder
erkrankungen generell in dieser
altersgruppe minimiert das jetzt nicht
etwas für die gesamtbevölkerung aber
etwas was in solchen fällen also
menschen mit dem schweren risiko für
einen schweren verlauf wirklich von
vorteil sein kann ärgert sie eigentlich
als philologe muss ich auch mal
persönlich fragen sie sind ein
renommierter aids forscher dass man bald
mit dem medikament die lösung gefunden
hat dass das aber balkon aso noch nicht
funktioniert na ja weil man muss sich
auch mal die entwicklung bei der hiv und
aids forschung anschauen die
ahv also das virus wurde 82 entdeckt und
es hat dann trotzdem noch ja bis 84 87
gedauert bis man das erste medikament
hatte in der zwischenzeit sind sehr sehr
viele menschen an aids verstorben was
natürlich schade ist und da auch der
politische wille fehlt ist dass wir viel
zu wenig investieren in hiv-impfstoff
forschung der letzte hiv-impfstoff
versuch ist ja gescheitert mit einer
effektivität von 25 prozent und wir
haben ein crooner sehr deutlich gesehen
wenn der politische wille ist und auch
die fördermöglichkeiten da sind dann
findet man auch einen weg einen
impfstoff zu finden
impfstoffe gibt es auch gegen grippe die
alljährliche und die einen sagen immer
ja ich mache das die anderen sagen na ja
da wird schon nicht so viel schief gehen
jetzt fragen sich natürlich viele wenn
ich kroner geimpft bin zweimal geimpft
bin vielleicht sogar noch einen booster
impfung bekommen ende des jahres macht
das dann eigentlich noch sinn eine
normale grippeimpfung auch noch auf sich
zu nehmen also
letztes jahr hatten wir ja keine
grippewelle die ist ja wirklich
ausgeblieben dieses jahr wissen wir
nicht wie es sich entwickelt wir haben
in der südhalbkugel bisher sehr wenig
grippefälle gesehen so dass man
wahrscheinlich auch nicht davon ausgeht
ein viele grippefälle zu bekommen trotz
allem ist es sinnvoll sich impfen zu
lassen wenn man risiko für einen
schweren verlauf hat also über 60 jahre
ist zum beispiel oder schwanger ist wird
angeraten eine grippeimpfung zu nehmen
man muss sich das so vorstellen das sind
unterschiedliche
sport teams die da trainieren auf der
einen seite haben wir das fußball team
was gegen korona trainiert und auf der
anderen also das handball team das gegen
die grippe trainiert die kommen sich
nicht in die quere beim trainieren da
kann man sogar die impfungen
gleichzeitig geben und ist wird ein
zusätzlicher schutz eben beim training
des immunsystems auf den verschiedenen
ebenen aufgebaut ist eine grippeimpfung
schon zu empfehlen da ist also keine
sorge berechtigt das immunsystem
überzustrapazieren
nein man kann das immunsystem nicht mit
zu vielen impfungen überstrapazieren
wenn wenn es sich um solche tote im
stoffe handelt man bei einigen leben
dämmstoffen da macht man keine
kombination der impfstoffe aber das ist
dann wirklich den tiefen der der axino
logi in die wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht einsteigen wollen aber in diesen
fällen ist es gibt es keine sorge da
dass man da was falsch macht wenn man
eine impfung gleichzeitig gibt und wir
haben ja jetzt auch genug über die kurve
neun zehn impfungen gelernt so dass wir
da auch die nebenwirkung im vergleich
zur grippeimpfung
dort die nebenwirkung ganz gut
abschätzen kann hat ja im letzten jahr
gesagt die grippe ist eigentlich
deswegen ausgeblieben weil wir mit maske
um gelaufen sind es gibt jetzt schon
wieder eine neue diskussion darüber ob
man nicht auf die masken komplett
verzichten könnte vor allen dingen auch
in schwung da sind die bundesländer auch
sehr unterschiedlicher ansicht wie ist
ihre einschätzung ja also wir sehen
deutlich auch mit einer kürzlichen
studie von ac dc dass die masken es
schaffen die infektionsraten zu
reduzieren auch vor allem an schulen das
durch das wachsen tragen eine infektion
beim schülern und schülerinnen reduziert
ist generell ist eine profit 19
infektionen bei kindern und jugendlichen
ja weit weniger gefährlich als bei
erwachsenen also wirklich ungleich
weniger
trotz allem sollte man im herbst und
winter jetzt überlegen ob man
experimente anfangen will also maske
weglassen
hygienemaßnahmen fallenlassen freedom
day auszurufen das ist eben etwas was
man für ein winter vielleicht nicht
gleich anraten sollte wo man ja nicht
weiß wie die entwicklung sein wird
generell bin ich aber auch dafür dass
wir in dieser übergangsphase in der wir
uns befinden von pandemie zu random auch
anfangen müssen beschränkungen oder
maßnahmen zurückzunehmen aber wir müssen
genauso schnell sein dass wir die dann
auch wieder einführen heißt die zahl
zahlen so hochgehen falls sie gerade
nochmal die fallzahlen ansprechen da
müsste man dann eben tatsächlich ganz
genaue zahlen haben und ganz genau
entscheiden können aufgrund dieser
zahlen belege müssen wir dies oder jenes
möglicherweise zurückfahren oder können
dann öffnen ja und diese zahlen liegen
ja überhaupt nicht vor wir hatten jetzt
zb ende des sommers diese situation dass
wir glaubten dass bei den schülern vor
allem ein anstieg der infektionszahlen
ist das ist aber gar nicht so gewesen
weil wir vor allem nach dem ende der
schulferien vor allem die schüler und
schülerinnen getestet haben also das war
eine wirklich durch die anstieg der test
frequenz in dieser altersgruppe haben
wir ein anstieg der fallzahlen in der
altersgruppe auch gesehen wir brauchen
vielmehr repräsentative stichproben um
genau zu sagen wie hoch die inzidenz in
deutschland eigentlich ist muss man das
sie sind ja auch im kreis der experten
in nordrhein- westfalen mit dem immer
noch amtierenden ministerpräsidenten
laschet da ist sehr viel überlegt worden
auch aus dem augenblick heraus machen
wir dies machen wir jenes also das ist
sehr genau verfolgt worden was da
passiert in nordrhein westfalen
kann man daraus lernen für die
institutionen auch in deutschland weil
sie zum beispiel auch angesprochen also
in jedem fall ich glaube das wäre eine
vertane chance wenn wir nicht für die
nächste pandemie die vielleicht in 20
jahren oder wann auch immer passieren
kann
dass wir hier bessere strukturen
schaffen besser daraus lernen die wir
auch so eine pandemie reagieren aber
auch institutionen wie das lka dahin
gehen
mit befugnissen ausstatten dass die auch
unabhängig arbeiten können unabhängig
zahlen erfassen können nicht direkt
immer von der politik eben abhängig sind
und dadurch auch unabhängige statements
oder aussagen treffen können weil zum
teil
muss man sich schon fragen warum
bestimmte
daten nicht erhoben wurden oder auch
besser kommuniziert wurden stichwort zum
beispiel die impfquote wo wir doch
eigentlich die möglichkeit hätten von
der digitalisierung und von der struktur
in deutschland da auch bessere daten zu
erfassen wir haben jetzt eine große
bandbreite an impfstoffen zur verfügung
es gibt jetzt immer noch diskussionen
ist es besser mit dem einen oder mit dem
anderen impfstoff
vorzusorgen wird es irgendwann den
impfstoff gegen korona geben oder wird
es immer eine mixtur geben an angeboten
ja also für für krippe haben wir ja auch
eine mixtur von vielen verschiedenen
anbietern die ja unterschiedliche
kombinationen oder auch mal einen
impfstoff der über die nase gegeben wird
oder gespritzt hat dieses nasenspray
irgendwann das muss man sehen das muss
in den klinischen studien getestet
werden wie gut es funktioniert das ding
noch keine daten vor aber ich kann mir
gut vorstellen dass das so was vor allem
für kinder geben wird dass sie auch bei
der grippeimpfung dass es für kinder vor
allem ein nasenspray gibt das ist ein
angenehmer einer anwendung macht aber
auch ein bisschen andere immunantworten
was vielleicht auch interessant sein
kann vielleicht auch einen besseren
prophylaktischen schutz gegen das virus
gibt ich nehme schon an dass sie eine
bandbreite von verschiedenen impfstoffen
haben werden in zukunft auf gegen korona
und einige
vielleicht ein bisschen höhere
effektivität aber die firmen arbeiten ja
sehr daran die die impfstoffe die es
gibt auch noch zu verbessern und
vielleicht auch noch andere varianten
mit abzudecken so der zeitleiste mal
sehen hier auf der linken seite ist
pandemie und das ende mai wo stehen wir
denn da ungefähr ja wir sind genau in
dieser übergangsphase und das ist eine
undefinierte zeit und in dieser
undefinierten zeit muss man natürlich
schauen wie man da auch gut mit
maßnahmen vorgeht aber
wir wissen natürlich auch dass wir im
herbst und winter aufgrund der
saisonalität er mit dem anstieg der
fallzahlen zu rechnen haben aber im
frühjahr auf wieder mit einem abfall der
fallzahlen jetzt kommt dazu wir haben
viele geimpfte wir werden
sehen wie der herbst und winter verläuft
aber im frühjahr dann diesen abfall
haben so dass man schon damit rechnen
kann dass man dann auch in die ende mai
eingetreten das was bedeutet das dann im
alltag ja es bedeutet eben leider dass
das corona virus immer noch da sein wird
das wird auch wahrscheinlich in 15
jahren immer noch da sein aber es ist
nicht mehr so schlimm es kommt im herbst
und winter immer wieder zu der welle
also eine dauerwelle über die jahre
hinweg und wir werden dann im aber keine
schutzmaßnahmen mehr brauchen weil wir
den impfstoff haben wenn jemand dann
doch mal erkrankt ist dass er dann
vergleichbar mit einer grippe obwohl
diese vergleiche virologen nicht gerne
machen professorin trick strikt danke
dass sie wollen mir waren vielen dank
meine damen und herren und ja wir hoffen
dass die entwicklung so weiter verläuft
wie sie sich im handel im augenblick
andeutet es gibt keine entwarnung es
könnte ja eine neue welle drohen man
muss also aufpassen aber mit den
impfstoffen sind wir ein riesen stück
vorangekommen und ich bedanke mich für
ihr interesse war sie die natürlich noch
einmal darauf hin dass sie das alles in
den mediatheken und bei phoenix de sich
nochmal anschauen können vielen dank für
ihr interesse
[Musik]
tief im osten der republik die lausitz
man konnten uns drauf und sagt hier ist
mein zuhause und das ist für mich heimat
ich bin